I've been playing lightning returns
final fantasy 13 for a few days now and
it's strange that after two previous
games in this universe but I don't feel
like I know the heroine named lightning
all that well I know she's the world's
Savior awoken after 500 years by boon of
Elza that is god I know she must save as
many souls as she can before chaos
consumes the world in a matter of days
but i don't really know her even she is
surprised by her lack of emotion god has
promised her that she will be reunited
with her lost sister Sarah as a reward
for her sacrifices but lightning isn't
moved or excited by the notion and
doesn't fully know why returning
character hope tells her it's because
she's evolving into a DD herself but
when a story's main character doesn't
care it's hard for the viewer to care if
you thought Lightning was stoic before
she's really a blank canvas now
lightning now does battle all on her own
and doesn't have a group of friends to
provide breaks in the stories pacing I
like the battle system though which
molds the previous games paradigm shifts
into a combat mechanic that keeps me
switching between assigned roles called
squamata lightning keeps in contact with
hope who chatters so much that the game
is constantly cutting him off with
various triggered events and
conversations it seems the order has
been trying hard to recover the relic
in recent years they've dispatched
several bars of spectators to the desert
you're so eager to die
but without an adventuring party the
balance lightning stoicism lightning is
the hollow shell that she says she is
and so I'm not very invested in
lightnings rescuing duties and random
fetch quests at this stage but I'm
intrigued by the game's depiction of
religion and the religious boon of Elsa
is sometimes referred to by name but is
typically known as god with a capital G
with lightning cast as the Savior it's
not difficult to draw the obvious
parallels between boon of Elsa and
Jehovah and even hope in his hovering
craft would seem to be a holy angel
acting as lightning spiritual guide
eventually the story both fulfills its
Christian allegories and subverts them
though sharing exactly how would spoil
important plot points meanwhile a
murderous cult echoes the book of
Matthew chapter 2 in which Herod
commands the slaughter of all newborn
boys throughout Bethlehem Japanese
role-playing games have never shied away
from religious and mythological themes
after all killing deities as a popular
pastime in such games but it's rare that
such a game would so closely mirror the
stories of the Bible as for lightning
she's a reluctant Savior leaving me to
find other ways to quench my thirst for
adventure in places like the aptly named
dead dunes lightning skims down heaps of
sand as if she's surfing the locals tell
me there's treasure out there to be
found I'll be more excited however if i
can find exactly what makes lightning
tick so now I this the bed way you save
myself
I could help you if that's what you want
damn it what kind of answer is that oh
no that isn't going to work